un message d'information qui défilent
des agents en gilet rouge pour
renseigner les voyageurs
depuis la fermeture de la ligne entre la
verrière et la défense pour des raisons
techniques
les usagers doivent faire preuve de
patience et il en faut mais dix habitent
plus tôt et vient travailler à saint
quentin en yvelines
avant c'était six stations et 45 minutes
aujourd'hui c'est le double je prends le
tramway t2 jusqu'à ici va ciel puis le
rer c et jusqu'à 50 on y vit déjà ces
longs 45 minutes c'est long maintenant
c'est multiplier par deux son coeur
faut vivre avec à la descente du train
toujours des ajoncs pour renseigner et
toujours le même message que l'on peut
entendre ils se sont même drôlement
améliorée au niveau de la communication
ça fait une trentaine d'années cheveux
en les transmettant des informations
claires précises qui temporise
l'agacement des usagers rencontrés ce
soir bonjour semences maintiens que je
sais pas réellement les dégâts qu'il ya
c'est vrai que c'est important chance
alors maintenant on peut toujours se
poser des questions c'est pas pour ça
que ça va changer les choses
d'autres trouvent des parades comme ceux
par exemple qui viennent de loin pour
garder leurs petits enfants le mercredi
un an je suis rentré mercredi soir et ça
pénalise un peu mes enfants parce que
c'est eux qui sont obligés de déposer
enfin la crèche et ce alors ça les met
pas en avance en tête la ligne vue
devrait rester interrompu pendant encore
deux semaines un trafic stoppée en
raison d'un incendie survenu au poste de
signalisation de sèvres-ville d'avray
la sncf propose quatre itinéraires de
substitution soit en passant par issy
val de seine soit par la ligne paris
montparnasse